sterben bald alle Bananen aus wenn ihr
im Supermarkt eine Banane kauft dann ist
das meistens die kevinish Banane und
jetzt kommt das Problem durch ihre
geringe genetische Vielfalt ist sie sehr
anfällig für die Panama Krankheit und
die breitet sich weltweit immer
schneller aus und unsere bananen haben
bisher keine Verteidigung dagegen aber
hier könnte die Gentechnik ins Spiel
kommen man könnte gezielt Gene in die
Pflanze bringen die sie Resistent machen
mit Gentechnik und modernen Gene editing
Methoden wie der genschere crispc 9 kann
man gezielte und kleine Eingriffe ins
Genom vornehmen diese Änderungen sind so
klein dass sie von natürlichen
Veränderungen gar nicht zu unterscheiden
sind es gibt bereits Studien in denen
zwei verschiedene transgene kevinis
Bananen getestet wurden die eine erhielt
ein einzelnes Gen von einem Fadenwurm
der mit dem Pilz der die Krankheit
auslöst im Erdboden lebt und die andere
hatte ein Gen von einer resistenten
wildbanane erhalten die Ergebnisse sehen
vielversprechend aus hoffentlich müssen
wir uns bald nicht mehr fragen